You know, usually when we talk about a medical diagnosis, there is an expectation
of precision that looks a lot like engineering.
Oh, totally.
Yeah.
It's usually very cut and dry.
Right.
You have a specific set of symptoms.
You run a test, you match it to a specific disease and bam, there you have it.
Exactly.
I mean, a broken bone looks fundamentally different on an x-ray from say a torn ligament.
Yeah.
Or like asthma sounds completely different in a stethoscope than a heart attack does.
Right.
Because it's almost always categorized by the physical presentation.
The, uh, the, what is really the defining factor in most of medicine.
Exactly.
But then you look at the material you sent us for today's deep dive into
psychotic spectrum disorders and you realize that entire traditional paradigm
is just, well, it's thrown right out the window.
It really is.
It's wild.
Because with these disorders, the symptoms can actually be identical.
Yeah.
Like the exact same presentation, the same hallucinations, the same behavior.
The only thing separating one diagnosis from another, the only thing
separating like a temporary blip from a lifelong condition is a clock.
It is incredibly counterintuitive at first glance.
I mean, we aren't measuring antibodies or, you know, running
scans to separate these conditions.
Time is the ultimate diagnostic tool here.
And that is exactly what we're going to explore today.
Welcome to this deep dive.
Glad to be here.
We are looking directly at the study notes you sent over and you're
clearly prepping for a major exam or perhaps, uh, a high stakes clinical meeting.
Oh yeah, these notes are intense.
They really are.
So our mission today is to decode this information.
We're going to take these dense diagnostic criteria, these F codes, and
basically transform them into an unforgettable mental map for you.
Because when you were sitting in that exam room or facing a real
patient in a clinical setting, you do not want to be fishing around
from memorized bullet points.
No, definitely not.
You want a framework that intuitively makes sense.
You need to know not just what the rules are, but you know, why
they exist in the first place.
Okay, let's unpack this.
We really need to introduce the core framework right away.
Yeah, let's lay the groundwork.
So I want you to imagine a stopwatch.
There's a stopwatch running in the background of a patient's life
from the exact moment their psychotic symptoms begin.
A stopwatch.
Okay.
I like that.
Right.
And the moment you hit stop on that watch, whether it's a few days,
a few months, or longer, that is what determines the diagnosis.
It's like climbing a ladder built entirely out of duration.
A ladder of time is a really helpful visual, but before we even
step onto the first rung of that ladder, there is a foundational
rule in the material that we have to establish.
Oh, right.
We have to clear the ground entirely.
Exactly.
The absolute baseline rule always rule out of substance and always
rule out a medical cause before you even think about landing
on a primary psychotic disorder.
This is non-negotiable in psychiatry, isn't it?
It is completely non-negotiable.
And if we connect this to the bigger picture, the reason why this
matters so much is the danger of clinical anchoring.
Clinical anchoring.
Yeah.
So imagine you're the clinician, a 22 year old walks into the
emergency room, absolutely terrified, experiencing severe
visual hallucinations and paranoid delusions.
Okay.
It is very easy to immediately jump to that psychotic
spectrum ladder and just, you know, start the stopwatch.
So essentially we can't even start looking at the clock until
we're absolutely certain the symptoms aren't being driven
by something else.
Like maybe a drug interaction or a neurological issue.
Exactly.
Because if you jump straight to a psychotic disorder without
checking their blood work or doing a neurological exam, you
might miss something massive.
Like what?
Well, what if those hallucinations are being caused by
severe amphetamine intoxication or, uh, alcohol withdrawal?
Oh, wow.
Yeah.
Or what if it's an underlying medical issue, like a brain
tumor, autoimmune encephalitis, or even a severe systemic
infection causing delirium?
Right.
Because if you just slap a psychiatric label on them and
send them to the psych ward, you could lead that patient
down an entirely incorrect and potentially really dangerous
treatment path.
Exactly.
You have to prove the building is structurally sound before
you start arguing about what color to paint the walls.
You know, that makes total sense.
You are looking for a primary psychotic disorder, which
means the psychosis is the main event, not just a
secondary side effect of something else.
Once you've cleared the ground, then you can pick up
the stopwatch.
Okay.
So the ground is cleared, blood work is clean, no
neurological red flags.
We are ready to step onto the very first rung of
the duration ladder.
Let's do it.
This brings us to brief psychotic disorder.
Now, I see the diagnostic code F23 here in the notes.
Before we get into the timing, what actually is
an F code?
We see these everywhere in the medical material.
That's a great clarifying question, actually.
F codes are just part of the ICD, the International
Classification of Diseases, the coding system.
Yeah.
It's the global standard for diagnostic coding used
by doctors and insurance companies everywhere.
The F chapter specifically covers mental, behavioral,
and neurodevelopmental disorders.
Got it.
So when you see F23 or F20, it's just the universal
billing and tracking language.
Okay.
That clears that up.
So for brief psychotic disorder, F23, let's
look at the parameters of that stopwatch.
Right.
The psychotic symptoms last at least one day, but
strictly less than one month.
Less than one month, right.
And the defining characteristic here is that
it ends with a full return to the person's
previous level of functioning.
It's also, uh, often triggered by a major stressor.
Yeah.
And if we connect this to the bigger picture,
that phrase full return to previous level of
functioning is the real anchor of this diagnosis.
It separates a temporary break from a
chronic condition.
It makes me think of a storm actually, like
a really sudden violent storm that rolls into
a town completely out of nowhere.
It wreaks absolute havoc for a few days, maybe
a couple of weeks.
Right.
The sky is dark, the wind is howling, everything
feels chaotic, but then it just clears.
It's just like that.
Yeah.
The clouds part, the sun comes out and the
storm vanishes entirely, leaving the landscape
exactly as it was before the rain even started.
That storm analogy perfectly highlights the
mechanics of an acute stress response.
The brain has endured a severe event, often
sparked by massive psychosocial stress, like
a traumatic loss or an overwhelming life change.
Right.
And the neural pathways essentially become
overloaded and the person loses touch with
reality, but the key here is resilience.
The brain's ability to bounce back.
Exactly.
The brain's neuroplasticity allows it to
reset.
The storm doesn't permanently alter the
structural landscape of the mind.
They go back to baseline.
Which is a massive distinction, clinically,
less than one month, full recovery.
Exactly.
But I mean, weather doesn't always clear
up, does it?
Sometimes the storm just sits there, which
brings us to the natural conceptual pivot here.
What happens if that 30 day mark passes and
the patient is still experiencing psychosis?
Then the diagnosis must change, the stopwatch
keeps ticking, and we move up the ladder to
Schizophreniform disorder, which falls under
code F20.81.
Schizophreniform.
Okay, so the clinical picture here is exactly
the same as schizophrenia, the exact same
symptoms, but the duration is strictly between
one month and less than six months.
Right.
So is this essentially like a clinical
waiting room, like you're holding your
breath, watching the calendar, knowing that
if it goes past six months, the whole
reality changes.
That is exactly what it is.
It is entirely a provisional space, a
clinical waiting room.
The symptoms haven't resolved quickly enough
to be a brief psychotic disorder, but
they haven't endured long enough to meet
the permanent threshold of schizophrenia.
Let me push back on this a little bit
though, because looking at this from the
outside, it feels incredibly arbitrary.
I can see that.
Like, are you telling me that if a patient
has been experiencing severe psychosis
for five months and 29 days, their
diagnosis or their reality is fundamentally
different than it is the very next morning
when they hit six months.
I understand why it feels arbitrary, but
this raises an important question about
the statistical probability of
chronicity.
Why does the medical community use six
months?
Right.
Why that specific number?
It's because the data shows us that if
a brain can recover and reset, it usually
does so within that six month window.
Oh, interesting.
Yeah.
If the psychosis persists beyond half a
year, the structural and chemical
changes in the brain, particularly the
dopamine pathways, well, they are far
more likely to be chronic.
So you're trying to avoid a premature
label.
Exactly.
You don't want to prematurely saddle a
patient with a lifelong label like
schizophrenia and the heavy long-term
medication that comes with it.
If they are still in a prolonged acute
phase, that might actually resolve.
That makes perfect sense.
So you treat the symptoms in the
waiting room, but diagnostically, you
are holding your breath, watching the
calendar to see which side of the line
they land on precisely.
You are treating the distress, but
waiting for time to reveal the true
nature of the disease process.
And if they cross that six month
mark, the diagnosis automatically
converts, which means we need to
cross that critical threshold.
Right now, we are stepping up to the
top rung of the ladder, schizophrenia
code F 20.9, the top rung.
The stopwatch has now hit six months
or more, and this must include at
least one month of active symptoms.
Let's break down what those active
symptoms actually look like, because
this is where the diagnostic criteria
get highly mechanical and specific.
Right.
There's a very strict symptom
checklist here.
The patient needs two or more of the
following five symptoms.
Let's go through them.
There's delusions.
Right.
Which are fixed, unshakable, false
beliefs, hallucinations, perceiving
things that aren't there.
Auditory hallucinations, like hearing
voices, are the most common in these
cases.
Then there's disorganized speech.
Which is when the train of thought
derails completely, the brain just
can't string concepts together
logically.
And grossly disorganized or
catatonic behavior.
That relates to physical movement.
It could be extreme, unpredictable
agitation or even complete physical
immobility and unresponsiveness.
And finally, negative symptoms.
But wait, what about negative
symptoms? That term always feels a
bit vague to me.
Yeah, it confuses a lot of people.
Negative in psychiatry doesn't
mean bad.
It means an absence of normal
behaviors.
Like a subtraction.
Exactly.
It is the subtraction of function.
So a lack of emotional expression,
a lack of spontaneous speech,
or profound lack of motivation
and drive.
OK, so you have this menu of five
symptoms and you need at least two
of them.
But here's where it gets really
interesting.
Oh, definitely.
There is a crucial rule attached
to this list.
It is not just any two symptoms.
At least one of the symptoms must
be from the top three.
It absolutely has to be delusions,
hallucinations or disorganized
speech.
This is a vital diagnostic
safeguard.
It ensures that the core features
of reality distortion are present.
You cannot diagnose schizophrenia
just based on disorganized
behavior and negative symptoms
alone.
Instead of just saying the
symptoms look different, let's
think about how the brain
functions mechanically here.
OK, let's hear it.
If the brain is a sensory
processing plant, having
negative symptoms means the
machinery is sluggish, right?
The filter is clogged, things
are slowing down, there's a lack
of motivation.
Right. But having delusions,
hallucinations or disorganized
speech means the machinery is
fundamentally broken and
actively generating completely
false signals.
That is an excellent mechanical
analogy.
A clogged filter is concerning,
but an actively malfunctioning
machine generating a false
reality that is the hallmark of
psychosis.
That core break from reality
must be present.
It's basically a combination lock.
Combination lock, yes.
You need exactly the right
combination of symptoms from the
menu and the precise amount of
time on the stopwatch to unlock
this specific F code.
If you have two symptoms, but
neither is from the top three,
the lock doesn't open.
Right. If you have the right
symptoms, but it's only been four
months, the lock doesn't open.
Keep that combination lock in
mind for your exam.
And once that lock does open
and schizophrenia is confirmed,
the treatment protocol shifts
entirely.
Because it's chronic now.
Right. Because we are dealing
with a chronic condition, the
first line treatment is an
antipsychotic medication combined
with psychosocial support.
And the antipsychotics are
directly targeting those false
signals in the machinery.
Right. Exactly.
They primarily work by blocking
dopamine receptors in the brain,
reducing the intensity of those
positive symptoms, the
hallucinations and delusions.
But medication alone isn't
enough, which is why the
psychosocial support is critical
for long term functional
management.
OK, so we've mapped out pure
psychosis on this timeline
ladder. Brief psychotic is under
a month.
Schizophreniform is one to six
months.
Schizophrenia is six months and
beyond.
That's the core ladder.
But the human brain rarely color
coordinates as problems like that,
does it?
What happens when mood gets
involved?
Oh, this is a highly tested area.
And clinically, it's very
nuanced.
We have to look at schizoaffective
disorder code F25.
Schizoaffective.
Yeah.
This is where a major mood
episode, specifically a major
depressive episode or manic
episode, runs alongside the
psychotic symptoms.
But the defining criterion here,
the ultimate key to separating
this from everything else on the
exam, is that there must be
delusions or hallucinations for
at least two weeks in the
absence of a major mood episode.
Let's pause on that because it is
the absolute lynchpin of the
diagnosis.
Two solid weeks of psychosis
standing entirely on its own
without any significant mood
symptoms present.
Let me make sure I have the
mechanics of this trait.
Let's say a patient is severely
clinically depressed.
OK.
And during the absolute lowest
depths of that deep depression,
they start having auditory
hallucinations.
But the moment their depression
is treated and their mood
improves, the hallucinations
completely vanish.
OK.
That is not schizoaffective
disorder, right?
Correct.
That would be categorized as
major depressive disorder with
psychotic features.
Because they're tied together.
Exactly.
The psychosis in that scenario
is basically a shadow of the
mood episode.
It is entirely dependent on the
depression.
It only exists when the extreme
mood state exists.
So if the psychosis only shows
up when the mood is bad, it's
just a mood disorder.
But if the psychosis sticks
around for two solid weeks,
when the patient's mood is
totally fine, their depression
is lifted, their energy is
normal, but they're still
having delusions or
hallucinations, that is
schizoaffective.
It's like a guest who
refuses to leave the house,
even after the party music
stops, the lights are on,
and everyone else has gone
home.
That lingering guest is
exactly what you are looking
for clinically.
And this raises an important
question.
Why go to the trouble of
defining that two-week solo
stretch?
Why does it matter so much?
Well, I would assume it
changes everything about how you
treat them right, because
you're dealing with a
different machine.
Absolutely.
It tells us that the psychosis
is independent.
It has its own engine.
Its own engine.
Wow.
Yeah.
It isn't just a by-product
of severe depression or
mania.
Therefore, you have to treat
the psychosis directly and
robustly, usually with
antipsychotics, while
simultaneously treating
the mood disorder with
antidepressants or mood
stabilizers.
You're running two separate
treatment tracks.
You're managing two
independent disease processes
running in parallel.
That two-week solo stretch
is the proof of independence.
Okay.
So we've looked at what
happens when reality
distorts completely over
time and what happens when
mood is the primary driver.
But what about when a
patient's reality is 99%
perfectly intact, except
for one incredibly specific
unshakable lie?
Ah, yes.
Now we're moving to the
outlier in this category,
delusional disorder,
code F22.
This condition sits
completely off the main
duration ladder we've been
climbing.
The parameters here are so
distinct.
It's at least one month
of delusions, but without
any other psychotic
features taking over.
The behavior isn't
obviously bizarre, and the
person's functioning stays
relatively intact.
What's fascinating here is
the concept of a fixed
false belief in a person
who otherwise seems
completely fine.
Right.
It highlights the
incredible, almost terrifying
ability of the human
brain to just
compartmentalize
reality.
Wait, so someone could
have a completely fixed
false belief?
Like, they are absolutely
convinced they are being
surveilled by a foreign
government or that their
spouse has been replaced
by a body double.
But otherwise, they hold
down a job, go to the
grocery store, and seem
totally fine to everyone
around them.
Yes.
That is the hallmark of
delusional disorder.
Unlike schizophrenia,
where the architecture of
thought itself becomes
globally disorganized, where
the speech derails and
everyday functioning
deteriorates, delusional
disorder is incredibly
focused.
It's just that one thing.
It is encapsulated.
The reality distortion is
walled off into this one
specific narrative.
As long as you don't
reach that specific topic
with them, the machinery
appears to be running
perfectly smoothly.
That is wild to think
about. The delusion is just
walled off.
Now, the timeline rule still
applies, right?
It has to be present for at
least one month.
Correct.
But because those other
combination lock
symptoms, the hallucinations
that disorganize
speech, the negative
symptoms are totally
absent, they never
move on to that
schizophrenia ladder.
Exactly.
They don't have the
combination lock for
schizophrenia.
They just have the
isolated, compartmentalized
delusion.
Okay.
We've covered a massive
amount of ground today
from the emergency room
baseline to the top of
the timeline ladder.
Let's rapidly synthesize
the notes so you can
lock this mental map
here.
Okay.
If the psychotic symptoms
last under one
month and the patient
has a full recovery
back to their baseline,
that is brief
psychotic disorder.
The sudden storm that
overloads the system
but clears completely.
If the symptoms last
between one and six
months, that is
schizophrenia form
disorder.
The clinical waiting
room where we watch
to see if the brain
will reset.
Right.
And if those active
symptoms having the exact
combination lock of
delusions, hallucinations
or disorganized speech
cross that six
month mark, that is
schizophrenia.
The permanent threshold
where the structural
and chemical pathways
have likely shifted
to a chronic state.
Now, if you have a mix
of mood issues and
psychosis, but the
psychosis hangs around
like a stubborn guest
for at least two weeks
entirely on its own,
that is get-to-effective
disorder.
The dual diagnosis
indicating the
psychosis has its own
independent engine.
And finally, if you
have isolated delusions
lasting at least a
month but the person
is otherwise functioning
perfectly fine, that is
delusional disorder.
The encapsulated
compartmentalized false
belief.
So what does this all
mean?
When you step back and
look at this entire
category of psychiatric
medicine, it really is
just a clock.
We started this deep
dive by saying time
is the ultimate
diagnostic tool here.
And the mechanics
of these disorders prove
it.
They really do.
The symptoms can be
identical.
The presentation can look
exactly the same.
But the stopwatch
dictates everything
from the diagnostic
code to the
treatment plan.
It does. And, you know,
I want to leave you
with a final thought to
ponder as you continue
studying.
Something that isn't
explicitly in the
criteria but builds
directly on this
entire framework.
Oh, I love these.
What is it?
Well, we use this rigid
exact clock, like a
hard six-month cutoff
to the day to draw
lines between these F
codes.
It's fundamentally
necessary for exams, for
standardizing treatment
globally and, you know,
for navigating insurance.
Sure.
We need a system.
But does the human
brain actually operate
on such perfect calendar
exact deadlines?
Does a biological
disease process really
know the difference between
179 days and 181 days?
Right.
Like, does the switch
just flip at midnight?
Exactly.
Or are these rigid
timeframes just the best,
most practical way our
medical system can
artificially make sense
of what is actually a
highly fluid, messy,
human spectrum?
Oh, man.
The map is not the
territory.
The stopwatch is just
our best attempt to read
the brain's mind.
Exactly.
That is a wild thought
to take into your exam
or your next clinical
rotation.
Yeah.
Well, thank you for sharing
this material with us.
You have an incredibly
robust framework here.
You know the what's
and the why, and you
are absolutely well
prepared to ace whatever
is coming next.
Keep that stopwatch in
mind.
Yeah.
Watch the calendar and
you've got this.